the first thing is how do I tie what I
do every day to making more money in the
business you connect that dot and then
you improve that connection an
intelligent video editor is going to
come and say dude I can 10x the amount
of views that you're getting on this
thing because he's going to tie himself
to marketing if you're I.T then you're
thinking how can I decrease page load
times how can I get conversion rates how
can I organize the data in such a way
that the CEO can make better decisions
all aspects of the business can make
more money but people don't think about
it through that lens so the first thing
is how do I tie what I do every day to
making more money in the business
connect that dot and then you improve
that connection